okay so yes for Zen mode is still still
winning which does make things more
interesting um especially if I play like
let's say I play dubov I won't know I'm
playing
dubov uh and maybe that
will maybe that will be a good thing Zen
mode will encourage me to focus more on
the board than the opponent or if
somehow Carlson drops in I won't know
I'm playing
him um play sicil in this game
have a Rosal
liimo
and maybe
F6 F6 Bishop
[Music]
G4
and each
three I want to play this and then set
up taking and
taking white is doing things
[Music]
though
yeah I'm conceding the bishop hair
[Music]
here probably this
move
tricky if I had if I played this there
was Bishop
B6 to be really careful
here I mean one of the goals is to got a
knight to
[Music]
D3 we might see the bishop like reroute
to this
diagonal Queen D5
[Music]
wow
thank you cun with the prime
[Music]
sub which Rook to
move we might have the trade
here oh I'm losing a pawn
oops that's not good
that was really not
good I'm in
trouble I mean some chances
hopefully go back this
way
got to move much
quicker
O Okay I just beat
dubov I just beat dubov wow I was saying
earlier how like maybe I'm playing dubov
as a joke I was actually playing dubov i
d flagged
him uh and he didn't berserk
wow I just got outplayed the whole game
but somehow I survived like I blundered
this back ring idea was probably already
like not great for for
black
wow I've played duall before I've I have
been him before but uh not sure if I've
annoyingly being him